everything's about what's Joe Biden
going to do no one's ever talked about
the ecologist no one ever talks about
the endowment right no no what is the
endowment what's the endowment yeah I
hear that sees the endowments what is
the endowment exactly it's basically how
much money they just got sitting in
reserves right so given just money
that's been left to them or given to
them yeah okay tax-free stuff people are
donating people are donating getting a
tax credit and then that generates money
off of it does the government give them
endowment money as well I don't I don't
believe so okay I don't believe so but
even even from the fact that let's say
you have a college that has
um you know 500 million dollars I don't
know I'm just making up a number but
they're still charging your kid twenty
thousand dollars a semester right does
that seem like it makes a whole lot of
sense why is it so expensive not saying
it should be free but why is it so
expensive and on top of that you know I
was talking to Shane Cashman he was an
agile Professor they don't pay any
anything for these people and they hire
a whole bunch of adjunct professors so I
mean they're it's a scam it's one big
scam